you don't like eggnog I get it
the thing that you actually don't like
about eggnog is the boots not that it
has booze in it but the kind of booze
with people and use which will be like
rum or bourbon or maybe brandy and I
think importantly Jeffrey Morgenthaler
who's the bartender place in Portland
called Clyde common thanks but that's
the wrong boots and this is the
important part actually the eggs
probably report part
the secondarily most important part
booze we're going to use Morgan Fowler's
recommendations
kela and charity it seems weird but I
promise you it really really works so I
want to walk you through what has become
my house eggnog for the holidays
[Music]
eggs fresh American eggs are usually not
a problem you can look up some ways to
pasteurize them yourself I'm not gonna
do that
spin that up a little bit gently adds
sugar it gets that beautiful color I
love that
that's and we'll do nutmegs I actually
she's supposed to measure this I
actually eyeball them you can get ground
nutmeg in a jar but it loses the
volatile that make not make smell and
taste as good as it does else ignites
got an interesting history there used to
be a ton of these kind of drinks with a
lot of different recipes together
glasses in it sometimes they'd be heated
this would be the non-alcoholic version
the alcohol is gonna make this less
viscous which is part of the consistency
thing that bothers a lot of people that
eggnog
so 3.75 ounces of this this is the only
place that I diverge from Morgan Fowler
he wants to use in yaho tequila which
gives you a little bit of a taste of the
wood that it's aged in I like silver
tequila the sherry is Amontillado it's
delicious
this is gonna blow out if I
my grandmother used to make eggnog she
would separate the whites and the yolks
you know it gets that frothy egg white
whipped consistency you don't do that
with this this just blends it all
together you can not only pour one glass
for yourself if you're just having this
for breakfast have a good holiday
everybody enjoy your eggnog
[Applause]